it has long been observed that like
Thames to be get like however there are
variations within most animal groups and
some of these have a hereditary basis
let us follow a simple case of
inheritance in short horn appears
reading read mail produces firms each of
which carries in one of its chromosomes
a hereditary units or gene for red coats
this we shall indicate by a black tongue
a pure breeding white short horn female
produces eggs each of which carries in
one of its chromosomes a gene for white
coat this we shall indicate by a white
dot thus from a mating between a pure
breeding red males and the pills eating
white females every fertilized egg or
zygote will have one gene for red coats
and one gene for white coats a zygote
divides by a type of cell division
called mitosis in this type of division
the chromosomes arrange themselves along
the center then the chromosomes and
their genes duplicate themselves of the
two sets of chromosomes formed one set
moves to each daughter cell
note that each daughter cell contains
the same hereditary materials as did the
mother cell
since own cells of the body are formed
in this way each cell of the offspring
contains a red gene and the white as did
the zygote from which they came due to
the influence of both genes the test
will be wrong
let us now cross three grown animals
when a body cell gives rise to sperms or
eggs the chromosomes tear off instead of
lining up individually one chromosome of
each pair goes to each daughter cells
thus our own male produces two kinds of
sperm in four red coats and one a gene
for white similarly a lone female
produces two kinds of eggs in meeting
there is a random combination of sperms
and eggs this firm may unite with this
egg before a red red zygote which will
give rise to a red cap or it may unite
with this egg before a red white guy
goes which will give rise to a room
caste
this firm may unite with this egg to
form a flight rib zygote which also will
develop into a Rowan town it may unite
with this egg reform of white flight
zygote which will give rise to a white
cap thus from alone by room flaws we may
expect one-fourth of the offspring to be
read before it's loans and one-fourth
white guinea pig crosses gives slightly
different end results a few breeding
black male guinea pig produces firms all
of which carry a gene for black coats a
pure breeding white female produces eggs
all of which carry a gene for white
coats hence all zygotes resulting from
such a cross will have a gene for black
coats and a gene for white since the
zygote divides by mitosis all the body
cells will have both the black jeans and
the white in the determination of coat
colors the black gene dominates over the
white consequently the individual will
be black
now that is close to such black guinea
pigs this black male with cells like
this what is his firm's half of which
carry the black jeans and half of which
carry the white jeans
similarly the black females produces two
kinds of eggs in mating this sperm may
unite with this egg or it may unite with
this egg this firm may unite with this
egg or it may unite with this egg of the
zygotes produced three will carry at
least one black gene one will lack a
black jeans due to dominance of black
three-fourths will be black and
one-fourth white
risk Odom guinea pigs is also inherited
when a pill rough-coated male is crossed
with a pure smooth female every zygote
will have a rough gene and a smooth gene
rough is dominant over smooth
consequently all the immediate offspring
will be rough a meeting between two such
rough guinea pigs will give three rough
to one smooth
let us now cross appeared reading black
rough males and appear breeding quite
smooth females each sperm of a black
rough males will carry a black jeans and
a rough G each egg will carry a
whitening and a smooth
consequently every zygote from such a
cross will carry each of the four genes
black/white rough and smooth due to the
dominance of the black gene and the
rough gene every zygote from this cause
will develop into a black rough guinea
pig
let us now cross to such black rough
guinea pigs
when a black rough male produces firms
the chromosomes may orient themselves in
two different ways in one the black gene
and the rust gene may go to one sperm
while the white gene and the smooth gene
will do the other
in the other plausible way the black
gene and the smooth jeans may go to one
sperm while the white team and the rest
gene go to the other
thus a black rook male will produce four
kinds of sperms in equal numbers
similarly a black female will produce
four kinds of eggs in equal numbers the
black rough sperm may unite with each of
the four kinds of eggs the black smooth
firm may unite with each of the four
kinds of eggs
the white rough sperm may unite with
each of the four kinds of eggs the white
smooth firm may unite with each of the
four kinds of eggs are the 16 possible
combinations nine will have at least one
black gene and one Russ gene due to
dominance be the springy be black plus
three will have at least one black gene
but no rusty these will be black smooth
three will have no black jeans but at
least one Russ gene these will be quite
rough
one will have no blacks and no russkis
and this will be quite smooth
only when many litters are combined may
one expect this theoretical 9 3 3 1
ratio in this film we have shown
schematically the mode of transmission
of the hereditary materials which are
responsible for the inherited characters
of all plants and animals